[Music]
before too long you're gonna take on
this very taxing role of Macbeth that's
right and you are a serious actor how do
you balance late-night theatre and
having this point yeah having a family
how do you do it it's pretty tough
actually yeah the last play I did I had
it was a Brecht play
I was based on a Brecht play and I had
this white hair and I played this
drug-addled fool and I had eyeliner look
like David Bowie circa 72 or something
like that right and I was having a lot
of fun but then after the show
I never worn I make I make up before
yeah you might wear it a lot I don't
know put it on the minute I'm off camera
yeah Patra I had all this stuff on it
and then I go to bed and if you haven't
worn it before it kind of runs and looks
really weird waked but I didn't know
this so I would take my son to school
and I'm walking to school whenever
there's white hair and this eye makeup
running down my face and we get about
half a block from the school he's like
hey dead that's I just walk into the
cafeteria like we always do yeah I
appreciate it if you didn't your kid
blows you off yeah are you uh are you
exhausting I mean I have two kids it's
it's a lot of work it's exhausting my
wife does a lot of it but still it's
tiring my kids
she does she I have to give her credit
she does a lot of the work but it's
still it's still tiring and I have to
tell you I don't know do you ever think
back to your old days before you had
kids and do I ever yeah do I exercise
those time yes when you could just do
nothing and have go to the movies if you
feel hey I remember I used to you know
being an out-of-work actor it's a great
lifestyle if you don't have a family or
anything if you could just do whatever
you want I was like hey man let's go to
Mexico or something you know I could do
that it was a great life I don't know
why I ever gave that up
no I'm sick my daughter write human life
yeah it's funny this movie before
midnight is kind of all about that about
the different ways that love shape
changes and what these different moments
in your life and what's valuable at one
moment is different and how your how
hard it is to be in the moment you're in
right what's got like you know I'm
curious about something like when I
first saw you I think that the first
time a lot of us saw you was like in
Dead Poets Society and you know in that
you in movie you play very studious
you're very convincing is a very
studious person very studious serious
student were you a serious student the
time gonna get in trouble right now
well no I was very serious about girls
and about acting right it was very
serious about those two things school
was a lot harder for me and when I did
Dead Poets Society I had gone to about
two months to college and heard about
these auditions and I struggled so much
in college that I kind of raced down
this audition just praying that I would
get the part and and I did so I got to
drop out and then okay so I'm just
curious what you call this when you
called your parents to drop out came in
one course okay then you call your
parents up and you deal when they were
dropping out whatever say they said what
do you think your Clint Eastwood or
something you're gonna be an actor yeah
it's never gonna work out you know and I
don't know they were very worried about
my education as and now here I am I've
got a sophomore in high school and I see
that how much life calls young people
how much they want to have experience
and and how much I want for them to have
an education before they have the
experiences yes I am replaying the whole
episode from another vantage point right
now you're telling your kids don't do
what I did it doesn't work they don't
like that that's why I have to think
about everything I say in the show like
you asked me was I studious and I want
to say I was extremely studious Conan I
prepared for the pSATS every day
if you are serving with him now though I
had a friend in high school whose father
was so mad at him for not preparing more
for the SATs that he took the SATs just
to prove to his son that he could do
better and that wasn't what yeah the
father said I'll show you seven SATs and
he did really well that's very strange
I've never heard of that look at that